same brand same product identical
packaging same quality right
not necessarily that's the complaint of
some Eastern European nations they say
certain products sold in their countries
are lower quality compared to those sold
in Western Europe in Slovakia one study
noted that there was less meat in local
versions of the same products one wafer
brand was a less crunchy in Hungary than
those in Austrian supermarkets some
beverages contained more artificial
sweeteners you know life has all kind of
have alpha so either classic it if can
be accepted
thus invention amount entire opus full
name is emitting osterwald qualitative
left the label Jacobean I was in England
of work a pattern with Martin's party
prevent companies argue that they adjust
their products to suit local tastes and
ingredients are clearly listed on the
packaging
[Music]
meb is on the European Commission are
looking into the issue and discussing
consumer protection laws the Commission
released guidelines to help national
authorities assess claims that inferior
products are being sold in their
countries 1 million euros has also been
set aside to help finance such studies
[Music]